foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this
a Taryn Garrett
what up what up what up what up what up
all right let me eat all this out hold
on
howdy
hi Germany
I'm glad to see this I've been trying to
stream for like a few days and just
stuff kept getting in the way man
and we're here now
he's just standing there he is he's my
friend
don't you know this
Rick is a homie
Rick is the best all right let me shoot
out these notifications how good is
YouTube at notifications
they seem to be pretty good actually
twitch is terrible with notifications
but YouTube seems to be pretty good at
it if you have it on
I'm still gonna let Discord know hold on
I've come to talk about things I like
that
kind of what we're here for
yeah Rick's my homie he's fine
got it right away sick
you're on the front page when I reloaded
I mean that's good
[Music]
he's standing there
Madison Lee
listen he's fine
it's totally fine
is moog a god he's a demigod
you think the owls that dropped the
slumbering egg are related to Gideon off
near somehow the egg is used to craft
that to ward off Madness and sleep
that sounds more like mikola
than Gideon don't you think
yeah Rick is
God himself actually
doesn't that sound more like mikola
I believe the running theory is that
Saint Trina who has to do with sleep is
mikola
I feel like I heard that six months ago
I don't know if it's been researched
more
Rick is the god of the greater will
even the greater will has a God and he's
standing right next to us Isn't that
cool
Sun realm Shield item description I mean
I can read it
have you seen the videos from Smoketown
and tarnish archaeologists pretty good
content I've actually stopped watching
all Elden ring content
completely
and it's been probably good for me to be
honest
thanks Saint Trina's separate
I don't know that's the last I heard
but this was a while ago so that could
have changed
wasn't there a whole questline found
that wasn't used that had to go with
that I guess they cut it from the game
so we can't really like say that can we
why am I listening to clapping what is
the song stop
there we go
it's still the running Theory that's
what I thought
where'd you get the balls go next to
Rick like that me and Rick are buddies
it's because I made a video about him
and now he likes me
he's kind of weird though
the egg Wards off sleep and Madness
would allow of near to continuously
study
hmm
why would Gideon have anything to do
with
Birds though
or with owls they are kind of weird
though
I wish there was a little bit more to
the owls that are just randomly around a
lot of them have the they do all of them
have like the glowing eyes
could be
might be opportunities for collaboration
uh uh that'd be cool
[Music]
but I've more I've stopped watching
Elden ring content for my mental health
to be honest with you
I think what got me so confused about so
many things was because I was watching
like everything
and everyone would just say different
stuff and I'm just like I don't know
what to think anymore so I had to stop
yeah they all have glowing eyes
Gideon's weird it's unknown how much he
really has or how much reach he's like
he has a lot man I feel like he's been
around a while
[Music]
like one of the first tarnish to be
brought back
what's up Steven
Birds used to have ears but Gideon stole
them
[Music]
that's where all Gideon's ears come from
huh
it's pretty cool Austin
Gideon is responsible for Birds what it
what's the thing you guys wanted me to
read
this
hold on it's my camera tool the Gopher
spins
I think we have every item in the game
on this character
what up Rick
[ __ ]
I just did that
would you want me to read
my dumb ass went to the comment section
look at the comments
do you think it was a video
he's staring at me
menacingly
God damn
look at those teeth
Jesus
I think I might have to kill him
to get out of here
yeah I do unfortunate
you guys told me to read something no
one I don't know what it was
probably had something to do with uh was
it just a slumbering egg
foreign
of him it's not even really him the sun
shield
is that thing
there are a lot of shields in this game
and I just don't use Shields at all
it's just called Sun
Realm
Shield of Honor depicted a city crowned
by the sun it has seen better days much
like the wearupon The Shield the seat of
the sun is long faded away that can't be
it that doesn't tell us [ __ ]
was it
much like the wear upon the shield the
seat of the sun is long faded away I
feel like we haven't talked about that
at all
no I didn't buy the strategy guide book
wonder what ruin Rick has
oh you know
he doesn't need a great Rune he is the
father of the great rooms
slumbering egg is a symbol of most
Sublime Slumber that's what you want me
to look at was just the egg
this one
LA's that will never hatch prize symbol
of the most Sublime slumber
hmm
I don't know if we can look at that and
go yep that has to do with Saint Trina
and sleep
it's not a lot there
you know what I'm saying
no I'm saying bro
seat of the Sun
what would that mean
the seat of the sun I'm thinking of like
when the sun sets
it's like it's it sits I I don't know am
I overthinking that
you gonna make armor Decor content I
don't know if I like the game I will
and if you guys are interested
you're definitely gonna play it
I gotta like a game though to
make content on it
the seat is capitalized oh God
are we going this hard
with the uh
the
thinking
oh wait it was the shield on it
this one
the seat of the Sun
hmm
what are the odds that that is just a
grammar mistake
do they make mistakes in this game
it's like a zero percent chance right
seat of the Sun
what Castle is that hold on
this is why I like the camera tool
is that this Castle soul
oh [ __ ] I'm upside down it's hard to
tell
is this trippy
I would imagine that's just Castle Soul
right
implies talking about the city crowned
by the Sun
where does it imply that
[Music]
the Moonlight Greatsword was an armored
Core 2. I did see that that's pretty
cool
foreign
greatswords in every single game that
from software is made I'm pretty sure
that looks like the exact entrance to
Castle soul
the little doorway with the stairs
leading into it
I don't know if there's just like a
tower right behind it though
let's go look
we can do that can't we
because we're that cool and we hacked
the game
where are we at we're all over the place
Burr that's what we do on these
I mean there's not a tower directly
behind the main entrance here
is there another entrance
I'm gonna make this guy shut up because
he's
loud
I think you gotta do two legs on this
one
there's one
give me [ __ ]
let's figure out what the seed of the
sun is I want to know what it is
drop right
how hairy as me is there we go
is that not Harry
okay
so let me whip out the shield
main entrance with the tower directly
behind it
right behind the main entrance
I don't see a tower
uh it's close I mean [ __ ] dude and then
that would be the church right here
right
yep
I don't know I mean it could just not be
represented very well it could be just a
depiction
I honestly don't know where else this
would be
hi Jose
a ghastly
yeah artistic
Castle mourn huh
really
this would be like
the exact opposite
was a phantom do you say in the church
something about
being a [ __ ] or something
I need to turn on the ride anywhere
hack all right let's take a look let's
take a look let's get some distance
I don't think this is gonna be it though
boys
I mean it's not like that much bigger
right
uh well right here no no no no no no no
no
that ain't it
where else could it be
bit sad in it I mean let's go see what
the Ghost says because I think I think
it still could be this actually
search of the eclipse
shaded Castle huh
oh that's that's that's good that's good
that's the potential
dude [ __ ] that guy
what do you say
oh great son rigid son of soul
surrender yourself
to the eclipse
Rat Life to the soulless
bones
wow that told me [ __ ] nothing
like the voice acting
um
all right what's unique about you
Solace bones
he's got a horn
look at that horn
I don't really understand the fungi
everywhere
have you already explained your last
video no
did you guys like the last video
you know why I liked it because I didn't
talk at all
Nikola was here and then you get the
little sickle right you get this thing
let me just do my inventory actually
uh uh
what am I thinking right now
I need a weapon there we go
you get
what's it called
it's not called a sickle right
maybe it is
it's like the cert yep Eclipse shuttle
storied sort of The Treasure of his
castle soul that depicts an eclipse Sun
drained of color
okay in Seoul
the sight of an eclipse inspires a
dreadful awe preventing an onlooker from
averting his gaze
hmm
the same dude can be found in a cave or
maybe they refuse to reuse the texture I
mean there's ghosts everywhere mate
you like the last video
thanks I didn't I'm stupid and Mead [ __ ]
explained that's not kind of that's you
know not really the point of that video
by the way
it's more just like a cinematic story
telling of that questline
[Music]
do you think we'll ever
will enter those paintings for DLC
oh I think there's lots of places for
DLC to start I think the the most
obvious one is here
this would just make the most sense to
me oh [ __ ] I forgot about mug okay he's
gonna stand around
look he's gonna walk a little bit
and then he's just gonna do nothing
yep and stare right there cool
I think we'll go right here and we'll
touch this hand and we'll be teleported
somewhere
I don't know if it's a new land or a
different time frame but we're
definitely doing something with this
this meaty hand right here
I can't die happy until we learn about
America and nikola's motivations
yeah you cut it out Austin you quit
being silly bro
look how it bleeds
like they put enough detail on this to
like something happens when you hit it
do you still think that's not mikola
do I bring this up again and get Flack
from the entire community
again
if you guys didn't see the video from
like four months ago I made a video
claiming that this isn't Michela in the
Cocoon
and everyone's like bruh
Moog literally calls him michalon dude
and I'm like wow you're really gonna
believe everything you hear huh
um
to go more off that
I wanted to make a video about this
actually
I have a follow-up to that video I do
think this is mikola
but I don't think it's mikola anymore
does that make sense probably not
I did I think it's a valid question
I think this is mikola but it's not
mikola anymore
it was Nicola and now it's not
quite literally
how many of you guys have seen berserk I
just watched berserk by the way so I'm
gonna have some references to berserk I
just finished it I watched the anime
from like 1994 or whatever that's
probably didn't get all of it whatever
bro
this is literally Griffith
I don't want to spoil it but
you know how Griffith changes kind of
like that
where it's still mikola but not really
it's an almond clone
he was Nikola when he entered the Cocoon
but now he's moog's blood sex Beast
exactly that's what I'm saying
that
so when when Moog plucked mikola from
the halig tree
[Music]
he is now being used for moog's new
Dynasty
and with the formless mother he's just
being used
completely
mugged or wait who said Griffith did
nothing wrong
uh I don't know about that bro
can I can I spoil an anime from 1994 is
that a thing I can do
or would people get mad
I'm pretty sure Nicola is completely
based off of Griffith
I was like this is literally mikla
all right whatever if you don't want to
get spoiled then just mute
but uh the entire storyline of Griffith
is he's like loved by everybody he's
um super powerful
all his brothers in arms love him all
the
uh all the important people love him and
then he's [ __ ]
he finally loses
in battle and he couldn't take it and
then in
did some bad things was arrested
tortured for a year and then became just
a terrible being
awful
person I can't even say the things on
stream that he did by the way
I get in trouble for that word
morally wrong
did you see hacks of it again I do not
watch any Elden ring content on YouTube
anymore
I used to and once I stopped I started
getting really good at making content
again so I'm just gonna keep doing that
so no I have not
I don't even watch vati anymore man
uh it could it could Kutz
um tell people in chat that we're done
spoiling now
they all agreed to sacrifice themselves
for his goals
uh man dog it didn't look like it
foreign
I don't think uh they agreed to that
I love vati's videos bro
he's a disgrace for making [ __ ] up about
armored Core six
how did he make [ __ ] up how's that even
possible the game's not out
uh that was not Griffith
um
all I'm saying the guy submitted man he
did
he he wanted whatever to happen to
happen so I think it's his fault I think
there's a a moral conversation to have
about Griffith but that's why the anime
is so good I think I really enjoyed the
anime by the way you guys should go
watch it I watched it on YouTube there's
just all the episodes on YouTube
he claimed it was going to be souls-like
armored Core
that's silly no I won't
no shot bucko what up angel how are you
um the one on YouTube I don't think
finished but I did watch like an
explanation video of the rest of the
manga because I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna read I'm just not going to
um yeah
does that make sense
I I watch though I I watched a video
describing the entire story
it was like two hours long because I was
that invested in it I think berserk is
probably my favorite storyline in any
anime I've ever seen I thought it was
really really well done for how old it
is
Jeffrey Epstein is in the egg my my
whole point is that I don't think this
is mikola anymore
but this is uh mikola's body
but he's no longer the same person kind
of like you're saying big
which I agree with that
um
I personally believe your theory of
Michela is not in the egg I I know but
there's some things I didn't like about
my theory
which was a part of the theory was that
this dude
over here is mikla which I don't think
is true at all
this guy hanging from the ceiling
over here
is it this way yeah I need to turn on my
hack to ride anywhere I want
although armor core does have the same
story as Dark Souls if you replace Glory
Gwen with capitalism
uh I had a theory that that guy right
there is Nicola
idiot
she'll take the throne [ __ ]
I thought I unlocked the secret
questline did anybody else think that at
first
[ __ ] this guy man
and
then
become a lord
not even you
we should talk about why all these Dead
uh finger crowns are here
know what that proves that Gideon's just
[ __ ] wrong
I know in my bones that
a man can't kill a God clearly that
ain't true [ __ ]
because we prove we just literally
proved that wrong didn't we okay my
whole uh thing in the last video I made
which was a long time ago and I don't
think this would be true was that this
is Gideon
or not Gideon uh is mikola I don't think
that anymore
all knowing my ass he thinks he knows
and he doesn't
he's like the a perfect example of some
narcissistic person who thinks he knows
everything he's just a [ __ ]
is this
you have a face
nope
the magic spammer
probably killed by the Black Knight
assassin
by whose order though is that I think
that's pretty obvious right
that the black knife killed all these
crones that I think are trying to go and
um consult Queen America but I think
Queen America doesn't want to be
consulted by them the good night black
knife would be right here so probably by
America's order right
that makes the most sense to me she
doesn't want to talk to them so she just
has a black knife killed him over and
over again because they're gonna keep
sending a crone to her over and over
it's kind of like think of the Crohn's
here as just a bunch of uh
a bunch of calls from your ex that you
keep blocking you keep ignoring
it's like [ __ ] you no
uh Moog is maybe making more Omens or
something
I think there's a potential for that
yeah
I think it's something because clearly
the dude in here looks nothing like
mikola in the uh the opening cut scene
like app doesn't look like him at all
not even a little bit
get out of the way
he's way larger
we ever looked at this ring
it's a double snake ring
looks like one snake two snake are there
any rings that look like that chat
or any talismans
no it wouldn't be a ring there's like no
rings in this game
looks like roots of a tree it looks they
look like snakes to me
uh excuse me I'm gonna I'm I am going to
oh it's a triple snake
one two three
I'm gonna burp a lot by the way I'm
sorry I just burp a lot I do
but this looks nothing like Michelob dog
hey
Alden Beast is described as a vassal for
the greater will not the actual greater
will who is likely and corporal
right
no we never see the greater will it's
just a
the Eldon beast is just like a vassal
like you said yeah
I mean what makes the most sense to me
is that
here's what I think happened here here's
my running theory of mikola and Mogan
this whole deal right
Nicola was trying to create a cure for
Melania I'm pretty sure that's like the
main
point of the Halo tree right he's trying
to create a different type of archery
that has curing properties with unalloid
gold to make a cure for Melania right
for I believe that mikola needed to use
his own like imperian blood and his
flesh and maybe like some properties of
him being
uh
eternally young I don't know which one
could be all of them into this cocoon to
grow in the Haley tree to create the
Cure right
so mikola put himself in the Cocoon
and Nicolas started forming inside the
Cocoon started to change into something
else from what he previously looked like
then Moog just snatches them out
and then is using him for like some of
the same reasons like he needs his
Imperium blood or his eternal youth
properties something like that to either
make more almonds or with the uh
formless mother whatever they need right
so
I would I'm seen as mikola just being
Orchard
here using his blood clearly to uh
do something
right
that's that's how I see it
[Music]
we know the only thing we know that
cures
or at least subsides
the rot is unalloid gold correct
or is there something else
[Music]
is Eldon the real name of the greater
will I don't think so
okay corn
potentially I don't know
[Music]
but that's where it sounds a lot like
Griffith from berserk doesn't it
[Music]
I think a cocoon was made to create a
body that wasn't cursed like mikko's
original body was so he could properly
find a cure for Melania instead of a
stop gag
right right
I I think so too
yeah it keeps it at Bay but doesn't cure
it
so he's trying to make a cure from the
Halo tree somehow I don't think we know
exactly what he was exactly doing
but
he clearly got plucked out of the damn
tree before he could finish you know
[Music]
[Music]
any idea of what the giant head north of
inner aeonia is
it's bigger than the fire giant don't
think it's an outer God but maybe like
an older Beast
giant head north of the inner Ionia
in caled
is that in Caleb
watch the DLC make this conversation
even harder than it needs to be no it
will I'm already expecting the DLC to
make us more confused a hundred percent
skeletal Uber Giants
[Music]
the ones in caled right
kind of right below here huh
[Music]
there's ju there's multiple giant
skeleton heads there's also some in the
Forbidden lands
isn't there
that right is this what you're talking
about it looks like it has a fro hahaha
hmm
you don't know what it is
I always thought of this as not like a
person who got who died I always thought
of it as like the rot spreads like that
and creates forms like that
could be wrong though that's how I've
always seen it
where's the Forbidden lands there's
definitely some in here too
[Music]
we're talking about all kinds of stuff
tan
[Music]
that's how these discussions go
yup right there
talk about an area that nobody talks
about right holy [ __ ] the Forbidden
lands
at this point I don't know if people are
talking about them or not but there's a
skull right here
there's like several I think
I think there's one more I can't even
see where I am right now so
[Music]
I hate these guys
I wish you could charge
with torrent
I'm also surprised I haven't made a uh
an update for torrent like to give him
different clothes and stuff
oh here
foreign
[Music]
excuse me
two dudes sitting on chairs praying out
towards the ocean
in the Weeping peninsula
if you look at the map you can see a
vortex
for it is perfect as he is
[Music]
right have you guys noticed the weird
drop-off in the ocean over here
like it goes down
and then the water comes back this way
probably from the tornado
[Music]
I want mounted
heads or mounted weapons on torrent
the lands below
foreign
how did Moog even get to the Haley tree
these are questions that I don't think
we should ask because it's just going to
lead to like random [ __ ]
like
I don't know
how did one of melania's soldiers carry
her from here
to here
I don't know
because he's badass that's it
that was after her fight that what was
the Soldier's name frig right something
started with an F
didn't he use that portal it doesn't say
that anywhere I don't think
I was Finlay it wasn't a dude it was a
chick that's right
right
beaded
do you think the three fingers and the
two fingers were once
were once one being making five fingers
like a hand
what
probably not are don't they use
different fingers
or the same fingers
is the three fingers the index and
middle finger like I believe the two
fingers is
let's go look they may not even be open
but I can still look in the door
yeah getting still standing here
yeah
that's middle and index finger right
or is it ring finger
uh yeah I don't know
this thing's so [ __ ] gross I can't
tell
[Music]
that's ring finger and index how do you
know it's the ring finger
oh cause it's like right in the middle
of the hand right it's like right in the
middle of the Palm that makes sense
look like he got ripped off or
[Music]
ew
foreign
gross bro
I don't know we can go see what the
three fingers looks like
when do you think Niccolo was stolen
before melania's fight with radon
I don't know exactly
they don't talk in specifics in this
game it's just like
sometime later
which to these people could be like 5
000 years
you know I don't know and then to their
to them it's like
[ __ ]
tomorrow 5 000 years is tomorrow or some
[ __ ] right
three fingers is chaos two fingers is
order
they're like yin and yang
I've never heard of that before
can we look in here through the camera
it's not even here
oh I know what we can try we can do some
weird [ __ ] with the camera here guys
hold on I think I can pause the cut
scene
I have to get naked though everyone
close your eyes
you didn't close your eyes to do
okay
how do I pause again okay like that
okay hold on we're gonna do some weird
[ __ ] in the cut scene
pause it didn't pause [ __ ]
hold I gotta do it here I think
okay there I gotta do it from this
it doesn't work with pausing
I'm gonna pause right there you're gonna
hear the sounds though
camera on
still not there
okay
oh
this could be too scuffed
whoa whoa whoa what is that
dude don't you like how they just make
lighting out of nowhere in the cut
scenes look at that
is he here yet
no
okay
I'm trying to break the game chat
open
he's probably gonna frame out or
something
can we see him yet hello
dang I look cool
still hear everything I it still hasn't
framed over yet
what the
what the [ __ ]
I can't find myself oh
whoa
what the
look look where they put your character
[Music]
wasn't he right yeah there he is his
feet are through the floor
and then you're like the scene takes
place lower
where is it
was it higher
there it is
okay here we go
here we go
I can't do anything about the the focus
that's all in there like in-game engine
[Music]
okay
let's wait till he rises up right
like that yeah and then we're gonna
pause right there okay
there we go look at my character
foreign
okay that's pretty good
so what what fingers of this it looks
like a pinky
a middle finger
and a thumb
kinda that's a skinny ass thumb dog
[Music]
kind of burning away aren't they
he wants a hug
anything else we can look at here does
he have a hairy back as well
[Music]
this is interesting though
middle finger looks like it has four
joints and I hate it one
it's got two joints
it's rocking the two
[Music]
and then the the other two fingers that
are missing on the three fingers are the
are the middle the index and the ring
finger on the two fingers in the round
table right
that's gotta indicate that they were
connected at some point right I mean
they are their own individual Palms
though
maybe not
fingerprint Stone Shield or hold on let
me let me eat this up wait
telling you guys the camera is so hard
to use but I'm getting better with the
camera
let's get a hug oh
yo that's like wallpaper
almost
that was clean
hold on
yeah look at his fingers Bend
oh I don't like it get out of there
[ __ ]
they're more in this room
oh look at the middle finger Bend all
weird bro
okay let's look in the middle
I think if I zoom in with my fov slider
it won't blur out yeah
okay okay
look at that crater in the Palm bro you
see that
it looks like a dent oops
or am I tripping
he's scrolling on his phone we adapted
exactly this looks cool
Peppa Pig
snap
I don't think they come from the same
hand I don't think so either because
there's a bunch of different hands chat
a lot of them are dead right
a lot of them are dead as hell
all right let's get our hug
wait why is my character way over here
what oh he's not
let's get a hug boys
let's spread the love is that time of
year spread the love baby
let's get a nice hug
[Music]
um
yes augers
old old
and game speed
we gotta look
yeah that [ __ ] is burning bro
it's a good hug
it's such a good hug that it marks us
you know it'd be [ __ ] sick
if back here the entire time you see
Melina right here in the doorway
wouldn't that freak you out if she was
there but you don't you never saw it
just looking at you
oh that'd be freaky dude I that's the
kind of subtle details I like if if [ __ ]
was like that
cool
[Music]
nice
okay
nothing crazy there
honestly
Chad isn't updating yeah it freaks out
sometimes
[Music]
I don't know why
does anyone have a better like chat
browser extension for YouTube because
this one seems to hate it
[Music]
I'm gonna reload it
[Music]
all right quit looking at me I'm naked
let me get my cool outfit back on
now by the way chat
I don't know if we can do it or not
but we're getting real close to 100K man
like really close
and it's kind of freaking me out
I kind of dismissed the fact of getting
there
uh by the end of the year now I don't
know
it's a possibility
getting real close
my goal was to get to 100K before the
end of the year and I kind of wrote it
off as like nah that's not possible work
it's [ __ ] close man
[Music]
what are your thoughts on fingers having
legs that this sounds [ __ ] weird bro
what if Nicholas Eternal youth is cursed
is a curse he always has to solve he
would grow like anyone else but when he
becomes an adult he will die or some
explaining why so many miklas in history
are there a lot of Nicholas in history I
feel like there's only one
only 1.5 K yep
let's see let me look at the exact
number on my phone
98 582
so like 1400 a little over 1400 left
two fingers heirloom talisman
okay
two fingers heirloom
engraved with the legend of the two
fingers
looking at the emblem
fingers cannot speak yet these are
eloquent
persistently did they wriggle spelling
out mysteries in the air thus did we
gain the words the words of our faith
here's a theory chat
that I don't think anyone's ready to uh
accept
you guys ready for this
what if the fingers
are saying nothing
and the Crohn's are just making [ __ ] up
to feeling to look important
ever thought of that are you guys ready
to get yelled at
oh she's not here
where's she at I haven't met her yet oh
that's right she doesn't she shouldn't
even give a [ __ ] about me so if I go
back to the the front gate is she gonna
get mad
are they okay okay
that is basically what Vare says bro
it's kinda that's kind of it
what's she gonna say when I have the
flame of frenzy eyes right here by the
way this is my first time meeting her on
this playthrough
because I restarted just so we could
have the option to look at everything
frenzy's eyes right now
well if there's whole new dialogue
greetings Traveler
from Beyond the fog she's probably the
the directors are probably like yeah no
shot they get that far without torrent
bro
or being able to level
foreign
shut up melna
[Music]
hello video game
what offering oh
okay
okay this is all the same
okay
[Music]
will she yell at me here
you think like if I rest well is she
gonna yell at me about the the three
fingers
yep
yep sure did you want to know
yeah
we just started it
God that's such a cool line
for allowing you the strength that's
such a dope lion by the way
my companion if you do this I will kill
you as sure as night follows day isn't
that sick
that's such a good [ __ ] line there's
so many good lines in this game I love
this game Game of the Year by the way
hello
Game of the Year guys just so you know
in one game of the year
I'm still saying that
how long are you streaming for I don't
know
as long as my heart desires
glow my eyes unlocked game of what uh
game of the year
yeah if you didn't know the game one
game of the year
somehow didn't win best music
I don't even want to talk about that
and the reason she doesn't kill you here
is probably because she still needs to
regain her true form or something
similar uh I think so too
I think if Melina had the power to kill
us on that on the spot right there she
would have
well actually
she probably doesn't kill us right there
because we have not become the Lord of
chaos yet we still have a choice to get
rid of it
you know what I mean there's still a
questline that we can go through to get
rid of it so maybe she's given us a
chance before she absolutely yeets us
off the planet
imagine giving it to Ragnarok
am I weird for saying that the only
award I think Ragnarok deserved was a
best actor
uh Christopher Judge I think definitely
deserved that uh spot
for sure
but uh that's it
I don't I don't I can't even think of
anything else
yeah the musical score should have been
Elden ring a thousand percent I I don't
know what's up with that bro but
whatever
oh yeah best narrative ah dude
how many
how many of you guys have played
Ragnarok
I played it I played all of it
I don't want to play it anymore
I played it once and I'm done I'm like
okay that was cool
I will likely never Play It Again
but I guess that has nothing to do with
the narrative
is Ronnie gonna come out here
no I've gone too far
you will I liked Ragnarok too bro but I
tried playing the game again and I just
didn't want to
foreign
's narrative is really cool
it is
but
I can see why it didn't win
because I want you to think of the
average Joe right think of
your average gamer
they probably play a lot of cod
and they watch a lot of TV shows and a
lot of movies that's a nice scene
you think they're gonna take the time to
learn
Elder Ring's story bro
you know what they did they heard dung
eater and went
just like all of us did
vampire survivors Ludwig is one of the
best games I've ever played in my life
it is so good
Alden ring has a story
hey guys yo I got laid off two weeks ago
that's bad to come back last week and
today was my first day back reminder to
stay positive happy holidays wait why'd
they lay you off and bring you back do
you work for Twitter
I'm kidding man thank you for the five
and that sound that's good man good for
you I'm glad you've uh you're back to
work dude that was probably really
stressful
but I'm glad you're good now bro and
thank you for the five I appreciate it
did you like my Twitter joke anyway
there isn't any hand holding in from
software that's why a lot of people say
there's no story
yeah bro there's no uh there's no
questline indicators so I don't know
where to go so apparently there isn't a
story
yeah
I didn't find the story so that means
that there isn't one
right guys
God imagine if they tried to play like
bloodborne
they'd be lost in the sauce for weeks
can I get up there
[ __ ]
Mortgage Firm brought me back I did
three things no one else the company
knows how to do
hey they needed you man they just didn't
realize it well good for you dude thank
you again for the Super Chat I
appreciate it [ __ ] I'm bad at this
the game didn't remind me every 30
minutes about the story right isn't that
crazy
imagine the balls you need as a as a
developer to just like put a character
out over here
and tell them nothing
that's some balls dude
and they put this guy here to call you
maidenless
hey we're not going to tell you anything
by the way you get no [ __ ] too
that's some balls
to do right at the beginning
really is
yep no cinematics equals no story yet we
have the radon cinematic let's go watch
that I love the radon cinematic
is this gonna be open
[Music]
what was the network test dialogue I
didn't get to play it because I wasn't
relevant then I'm still not relevant but
I definitely wasn't then
LOL w
okay wait let me turn this off the music
and then
I'm tattooing the herd Tree on my willy
nice
I want to get a Melina's eye on my hand
I'm trying to get that set up but I
haven't been able to find a good artist
hey
tell me about redone
wait I gotta turn it up
not loud enough
hurry up
before we begin
allow me to paint you the full picture
my helmet
it's just a confessor's hood
we're done easiest boss in the game you
didn't play it when the game first came
out then dog
Rodan was a [ __ ] when the game first
came out they had to Nerf him like twice
or something he's cursed ever to wander
day one redone was absolutely [ __ ] by
Melania Scarlet wrought his wits along
gone and that was me by the way I was
there day one just want to say that
yeah
now he gathers the corpses of former
friendly phones alike his arrows at the
beginning never missed dog
if you're on target
[Music]
howling at the sky
yeah they did rebuff him though they did
he's still not as as hard as he was day
one
all right time to get smacked by a sword
the celebration of War
the radon Don Festival
[Music]
yeah
all right
[Music]
dude I want to go to a concert where all
they do it's just an orchestra of Elden
ring music I would so go to that
yeah you think they'll do a Boss Rush I
would love it if they did
like we they did with Sakura
I don't think he's gonna shoot at me
chat
Rodan took you five days I think he took
me five tries
I don't remember
yeah he's not gonna shoot at me
it's like Journey seven on this
character
I've gotten too strong so none of the
demigods actually shoot at you they know
they don't even try anymore
I'm just too big
[Music]
it's an eldering jazz concert I did I
saw that on uh tick tock
let's go check out this boat
I can take the camera out there
a night in the lands between that's dope
I want to be there in person though
holy [ __ ] this area is way bigger than I
thought
oh my God you guys remember sort of
Knight in flame day one oh my God
speedrunners we're going crazy with that
I came in I think it's just 2K
a game in 1440p
and Stream in 1440.
Steph that's certainly a boat
that's a boat
yep
boat
hmm
all right
[ __ ] boat boys
here there's the water drop off
oh that's just the bridge right yeah it
is
there huh okay
foreign
chat that made me laugh
where's the sea serpent
like the one on the map
isn't there one on the map
where is it
nope
where's the one on the map
foreign
make sure everyone stays warm at night
it's really damn cold this Christmas
Dude tell me about it it's like 10
degrees here locomotive thank you for
the 10 super chat I appreciate it
I really do thank you thank you thank
you
appreciate you
thank you thank you thank you make sure
you stay nice and cozy
this Christmas as well
this looks like part of the boat
washed up on shore
right
definitely
these are all boat parts
don't exaggerate it's in the 20s it is
quite literally 12 degrees outside right
now
hmm
the early version map has two serpents
it was Data mine though why did they
remove that
because there are not serpents
like War Quest wow I can't talk
sometimes WIC lore question why did it
take me literally 10 hours to beat Moog
on my first playthrough but this time I
whooped his creepy ass
uh you're better at the game because
you've played it
boom lore question done
I thought you're in the loo
I might be I might not be anymore you
guys don't get to know where I live
trying to think of what we want to talk
about or look at
I stopped at the volcano Manor and just
quit playing this game really Brent
the volcano Manor is so [ __ ] cool
by the way
I want to go look at it
is that here
[Music]
I can't imagine
I don't know man
does it doesn't it seem like most people
I would say it feels like everybody
liked Elden ring right
am I wrong about that
were there people that didn't like this
game
I don't know how you don't like this
game
oh right yeah Quantum TV [ __ ] oh my God
I forgot about that guy holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
guy
oh my god dude no [ __ ] way you just
got me like back into like March and
April this year
you just yeeded me back in time with my
brain oh my God
that's right
the videos on him were dude I who made a
video on him
the ax man I think I think his was the
main one
other devs hated Elden ring oh they're
just butt hurt they didn't make a good
enough game
they looked at eldering and said man our
[ __ ] sucks and then they got jealous and
tweeted
can we read the armor it's just a night
night's Cavalry and confessor's Hood
I did react to the it winning game of
the year
I was quite happy
I love it just don't have the time to
play hour and hours of grind anymore I
feel that Brent
I feel that bro
[Music]
Ronaldo is the worst boss in the game
who's your least favorite boss in the
game chat
which boss main boss don't give me some
side Rune bear [ __ ]
main remembrance boss who's your least
favorite
Miyazaki said he hates the games he
makes I doubt that
Melania
oh bro
hmm
hey Estelle
godskin
I would say my least favorite fight is
the godskin duo
no no no I changed my mind
I changed my mind
it's definitely one thousand percent the
fire Giant
I [ __ ] hate the fire giant with all
my heart and soul
foreign
he looks amazing but the fight is
absolute garbage
holy [ __ ] is he unenjoyable let me smack
away at this dude's feet while he
absolutely spams in his second phase
that insta kills you and knocks you off
torrent
ah
I think Eldon Beast comes second
and then God skin Duo the eldenbeast
I swear if if they allow you to use
torrent in the eldenbeast it's a great
fight
Elden beats would be a great fight if
you could use the Eldon if you could use
torrent
but you can't
I don't know if there's a lore reason
that we couldn't use torrent or some
[ __ ] but man bro
they needed it
and I feel like they could just pop that
in
but you know how often are people gonna
like come back and and play it again you
know
all right here's the next question when
do you guys think we're getting DLC
it's definitely next year
but win next year
you or maybe we don't get any DLC
and please don't call the coliseum's DLC
you're silly
that's an update not DLC
January 1st
hey y'all
we're getting DLC tonight I'm Miyazaki
damn bro confirmed
hopefully nowhere near Zelda
I don't own a switch so I'm probably not
gonna play Zelda
probably February you think it'll just
be a straight year
when did eldering come out
February something 25th
maybe a year anniversary
I'm gonna guess March
I bet DLC comes out on my birthday
sorry
might be at the end of the year to be
honest
nah
really
we're at the end of the year bro we're
there it's time
if you're gonna make it
put it out
all right armored Core comes out do we
know when next year though
I'm gonna go ahead and say armor core is
gonna come out like [ __ ] November
next year like literally a year from now
[ __ ]
look at our boy here
this is a Reichard correct
I'm pretty sure it's confirmed that
armored Core will not be a Souls game
I don't like won't be have any Souls
elements or very very it'll be a
completely different game
ring consort robes
is the furniture really fragile
I think they uh you know it's just fun
to break stuff so they let us Break
Stuff
they clearly didn't want Elden ring DLC
to overshadow armored Core 6 trailer
oh do you guys think a lot of the people
who stopped playing eldering will come
back
I feel like this is Reichard right
I'm asking too many questions
the armored Core 6 trailer was [ __ ]
awesome that's one of the best trailers
I've ever seen for a game
I think it's right card
it looks like a mask kind of like what
tanith wears
that is the same robe that TANF wears
right
wait
it might be
is it the house Mirai bro
if so
hold on
[Music]
where is it literally this
is that not the same room
oh it's this one wait let me look at it
again
it's blue
and I'm trying to remember the seal okay
blue
[Music]
no right
it's definitely this one
[Music]
uh I would like to Jay
robe with a black mantle across the
shoulders
the sons of house Mariah are all sickly
born house Mariah is uh
what is it
the uh Castle shaded Castle
and it's a boy toy
[Music]
I might quit Elden ring I mean you
cannot play it if you're not having fun
house Mirai is next to mount glennier
right
but it's it's literally this or this
right so officials Tire grobley
what is grubby grubby blue robe worn by
it
majestrial officials to carry out Grim
tasks surveillance executions grew some
rituals the darkest duties Drive the
wheels of mankind
facts
now then look at this mask
from I'm pretty sure the chick
that we kill near House Mirai
with the Giant
wears a mask
that kinda looks like the one in the
picture
why don't I see it
am I blind there it is it's a samurai
mask
because mirai's simp for Melania a
little bit too much yeah he did no no
kidding my goodness
he was a judge where did you guys learn
that reichardt is a judge
or was a judge where did you learn this
I need context to
know that
could be Lord Mirai himself
yeah I don't know if this picture is
Reichard
right
I don't think it is I don't think that's
right card because there's another
picture down here
oh who is definitely reichardt
sound reichardt on LinkedIn yeah that's
not him
this is
the title
what
his title is Prater
oh is that what that means
right sir right sir
that means judge
judge a what
get neat by a snake
that's definitely his face that looks
like the the face on the snake
judicial officer
a magistrate in Rome a Roman magistrate
ranking below Council
what are these on his arm
is there like old Reichard armor
anywhere
and then tanith is wearing this
I think her her robes tell us that she
used to be a dancer
isn't that right I feel like I remember
that somewhere
the tanith was a dancer and that's what
swayed Reichard to like
you know flirt with her or whatever
on sorts robe yep literally worn by
tanith laid over Lady of volcano Manor
long ago when Reichard first set eyes on
Tana she was working as a dancer in a
foreign land
soon I'm proud of myself for remembering
that soon he made her his consort
she was the only human to remain by his
side when he became the serpent of
blasphemy in that moment anith was truly
Charmed by him
so what does this tell us chat I think
this tells us that Reichard
has some game
he's got some rizz
as the kids would say
he's got the the charm the Riz
he's got it you know Riz card
wizard
dripped out man
did he join the manor or did he start
the manor
I feel like Reichard started the entire
volcano Manor thing
the [ __ ] is Riz where do you guys think
Riz comes from
uh never mind it comes from arisma
charisma
so you got the Riz you got the Charisma
you've got that it Factor you're good
with the ladies you know
you you know how to flirt you're good at
it
seduce [ __ ] like that
why tanneth never accepted the gift from
patches
uh she ashamed that she was a dancer no
I just don't think she gives a [ __ ]
about him
yeah I always assume that reichardt
started the manor
and then people fall chose to follow him
or or not you know
if he had Riz more than tanith would be
with him
I mean dog she goes as far as to eat the
guy
do you know any girl in existence that
after you died she'd eat you to become
you
can you imagine that [ __ ]
that'd be kind of freaky that's some
weird [ __ ] you know
you know a few I'm sorry
that's true love I don't know if I'd
want my girl to eat me chat
but that's how nuts this chick is by the
way
she also has cat eyes
oh that's what we should talk about
today you got like look at the [ __ ]
detail on these eyes guys
look at the detail on all the eyes in
this game are crazy
look at that
it has two different colors
and a lot of characters have two
different colored eyes
I think we talked about this in another
lore hunting video months ago but their
eyes are so cool
but look at look at the the iris like
she's getting red eyes in the corner
look at all the detail around the pupil
it's like her left part of her eye is
green and the right part of her eye is
orange
I mean let's go find uh some more people
that have different colored eyes does
this Crucible Knight I have a face
nah you you don't even
exist dog
um
where should we go round table I guess
that could be the lighting that's
definitely not it like there's too many
eyes in this game that are just like cut
in half and have two different colors
I think rodriga has two different eyes
eye color
sorry
this camera's hard to use sometimes chat
no she only has one color
I'm just like look at the [ __ ] detail
in these dude they didn't have to go
this hard with the eyeballs but they did
every character has like detailed eyes
except for huge if you if I show you
guys like huge eyes you'll be like what
the [ __ ]
look how pretty those are
but one side is light the other is dark
but I think that's still just all one
color
who has two different colored eyes it's
somebody
Horan has two different colored eyes I
think
when we when we get up in them guts
you know
let's see
no he has a big blue eyes that's right
a lot of blemish
look at those eyes man
uh we can look at Melina's eyes
but she she has
um her glomi is not under her closed eye
I remember that
big blue eyes
who else
[Music]
ophia's got two different colored eyes
if I remember right
Ludwig like God damn bro
yeah you can't tell me that's like the
lighting bro that's two different
colored eyes right there whoa whoa whoa
whoa wait hey hey calm down chat
what is this called when you have two
different colored eyes that's it's
literally called something right
like thigh something
that's blue and gold
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
I I just I can't believe the detail
on something you're really not going to
be able to look at this close
bro chromia did I say that right
yeah why did I say thymesia I don't know
ignore me I was wrong heterochromia
why do so many characters have that
[Music]
[ __ ] everyone knows there's eyes
what
yeah but you can't look at them this
close without hacks that's what I mean
[Music]
is that rare to have that
here I'm going to show you huge eyes and
then we're going to cut off it real
quick because it's gross
yeah
they didn't put in a lot of effort there
okay
I think uh
Oslo over here
this has one color
wrong button
One in a Million
Fame eyes is Corwin almost Oren
these are like a little bit more gray
not as blue
[Music]
heterochromia
not on this guy
also he has blood around his eye it's
kind of interesting
look at is Enya over here
not Enya
what's your name again
what's her name his name
you have a face under there
oh no you just have
Darkness
ensha
that's right
all right who else are we looking at
who do we miss I don't think we can see
his face
I think it's just a helmet
who's another guy uh
[Music]
can you look at Godfrey's eyes
they're gray literally just Gray
patches
ER
let's go look at Patch's eyes
blight is light blue eyes do we want to
go look at blood
[Music]
you're Brewery
we can look at shibiri
um I don't think you guys want me to
show you EG's face
it's worse than you think
much worse
well well
you come down here
[Music]
we're moving
oh God
laughs
I think his eyes are just blue
blueish Gray
[Music]
bluish Gray
Wallace and grommet
LOL
where are you gonna go
where are you going oh hello
oh I can't leave until I kill you
goodbye
took one hit
radagon's eyes he doesn't really have
eyes
I won't murder him
yeah I'm taking your [ __ ] too all right
where else are we going
okay I've seen a lot of godwins so we'll
check out Godwin
or the prince of death
Alexander uh does not have eyes he is a
pot
not a lot going on here guys
this kind of looks like a fish
I thought he was crying Golden Leaves
for a second and I was gonna freak out
they're just bugs
these golden leaves falling
what why are these here
plaster Deus ex's eyes are like huge
eyes
Melania does not have eyes they are
rotted over
we could go look at them though
how to reach the hidden face at the
bottom of Stormville Castle
um near the elevator you can just drop
down behind the castle
the elevator that leads you to uh godric
by the way
look at jiren
okay
[Music]
what's there to look at Ronnie we can
look at Ronnie
Melania Melina
game's a lot easier when these guys just
don't fight back
we already looked at fia's eyes they're
two different colors it's gray and gold
I don't even think she'll be here no
where did we want to go
dung eater has like gray eyes I think
have you tried America
you know what we could try and do
we have to beat malekith first though to
trigger
the cut scene from Erica
I can try and pause the cut scene
let's let's do this I'm gonna try and
pause the cut scene
for Queen America and radagon and see if
we can look at America's face while
she's still hung up you guys want to do
that wait I have to enter from here
sorry
or it won't let me go to phase two
it's like I've done this a few times
it's like I know what I'm doing
I I'm gonna try Ludwig
I want to point this out
have you have you guys seen America's
ass
I think no matter who you are you can
appreciate a nice ass but holy [ __ ]
kind of insane
it's like kind of crazy
don't give me the what a [ __ ] man you
know what I mean you can all appreciate
a nice ass
sounds intriguing
God damn
best with malachath no no
Ronaldo got the Pixar dump truck too
gosh I wonder why 98 of my audience is
male
hmm I wonder
let's look at this cutscene too actually
we have to do it like this though
I have to hit the game speed
from this menu or it won't work
I've never really looked at this cut
scene before like from other angles
you can appreciate a nice ass Katrina
thank you
everyone can appreciate a nice ass okay
let me go back here
can't wait okay bro I shouldn't have
even brought this up dog
I'm your two percent let's freaking go
I appreciate you
I mean YouTube tells me the analytics
man they're like it's two percent
look at that
um
you ever seen dust and death like this
chat
let's look at it from this way like this
direction
this is cool oh yep it'll just stutter
your character
and then we touch it and it should light
on fire red fire yup yup yup good
oh
no I [ __ ] it up I [ __ ] it up I want
to look at it
no okay got it I snagged it right on
time almost messed up though
I forgot the camera freaks out
oh
whoa whoa whoa hold on hold on
it's like only the middle section
watch this be read
who are you okay
I'm gonna look at it from here I think
this will be fine
wait what's out this way
nothing
I love how they do in-game cutscenes
put your dick in my
guys you shouldn't put your dick in
anything okay
just don't put it anywhere
I messed up the camera freaks out after
I go back in game
why not I mean just think about it bro
just think about it bro
just think about it bro wait what about
this
oh this isn't game speed this is just a
cutscene so I can't mess with this
why can't I skip
hello
literally can't skip
oh wait it's because the camera's on
there we go
[Music]
looks like an eye or something from
above
yeah at least don't put it in uh
Dustin Duff I think that's a fair shot
don't you
man [ __ ] Walmart Walmart can suck my
balls
what could have possibly happened at
Walmart that you didn't expect
like come on dog you know what I mean
all right let's see if we can just walk
in now hold on
[Music]
like do you ever expect to have a good
experience at Walmart because I don't I
don't even go to Walmart anymore
I just go up here
[ __ ] you
yeah I think I can just go in here
yup
okay
let me get everything ready
because it's gonna blow your mind chat
okay I'm gonna show it to you one time
you're just gonna be like what
okay
such golden Wyatt eat the sub
okay
that does pause it sick
so I'm gonna get the close-up shot
we need to look at this down there too
the the hammer
I'm not talking about the booty never
mind
and Bam okay
you're still gonna get the uh the sounds
but it shouldn't cut
what we're investigating the face not
her ass
uh okay wait let's get in a spot where
it's focused
and now I can zoom
enhance
there we go
dog
I mean
I don't think there's anything to look
at here chat
she doesn't have it she doesn't have
been asked she doesn't have eyes
okay
can I remove the cloth wait hold on
because there is an option to remove
cloth
why are we doing this
cracked pots now
grips
miscellaneous
I don't think this will apply to her
though
kill character reset bosses hide cloth
nope that doesn't apply to her cloth oh
wait
it's pause will it
wait I'm gonna
I get everything set up bro
so a little fast like we're moving at
least hide cloth
nope okay
so zero
you guys are
just
Beyond aren't you
I mean this is the lore everyone wants
isn't it
I don't think I can get the angle boys
radagon doesn't have eyes now
he has one eye but it's all like glowy
and then the other eye is just gone
how do I do this like I don't know where
I am right now
yeah never mind
it's got weird bro
where did I see it
you filthy degenerates
I saw it somewhere on YouTube
yeah we gotta do a close-up once she
picks up the hammer
like right here
oh this would be cool
wait so let's get into a focus position
and then zoom out
cloth removal doesn't work on America
still game of the year
still game of the year
absolutely
what is this Stone
whoa we're zooming way the [ __ ] out chat
okay
it's still pieces falling on top of it
oh
what's that
whoa
huh
okay that's normal
I'm like too zoomed out look how weird
it looks look how warped it is
The Shard that was in America this was
on the ground
before America was up there
you can see it at the beginning of the
cutscene
let's watch the hair change color yeah
so you do that first right
yeah look
[Music]
there it goes
it's pretty cool to look at the game
like this yeah
from these perspectives
it's better lighting
foreign
[Music]
here when we fight him
oh now it's really red
oh it changed scenes
whoa whoa whoa what is that
what the heck
why keeper there what
what the [ __ ]
why keep this
here
what weird detail huh
like changed
same position
foreign
look at this thing
I think you're supposed to see that I
mean no kidding like obviously we're not
supposed to see this this is a thumbnail
right here for the second Channel huh
take a picture chat
picture time
take a picture oh wait I can
never mind I can't
oh wait I'll take a picture over here
hold on I gotta get rid of everything on
screen
thumbnail
second Channel potential
look how weird that is you'd click on
this right
I'd click on it okay because my plan is
to put a
um highlights of our streams here on the
second Channel just to like you know the
main Channel this one is going to be
streams and the Cinematic lore stuff but
the second channel can just be like
whatever
look at this bro this is so interesting
that they kept it here
hmm
roof America is a mimic tear no you
goofballs
I like how this started with us wanting
to look at her yams
okay let's speed
why keep her up there though is there
like a moment in the cutscene where we
see her
and maybe they just keep the whoa
they just keep it there kinda
well no she fell so why keep her there
whoa this is cool
[Music]
so the whole that's why it's not there
Chet the whole thing is broken
just eats it
let me look at the hammer
maybe a model swap I mean couldn't they
just cut it
because it looks like it it Formed up
there whenever radagon became his
character right
yeah it could just be an oversight
that's the thing you gotta think about
here though is like there could be no
reason why that's there I don't think
there is it could just be like um
they left it there because they knew the
character would never see it and it
doesn't matter right but I'm like
literally hacking the game
but she's completely untextured although
she has some odd textures like that on
her leg and on her stomach and on her
chest
it's probably it's it's definitely an
oversight but it's just cool look at her
oh oh that looks no okay OBS bro bricked
are we good
give me a one in chat if we're good
because OBS died for a second
it just went I don't work
chat also if you haven't liked the
stream yet go ahead and do so
do it okay thank you thank you sorry
that was me
where's the Eldon B Spawn from oh we
should look at that next yeah
all right we're good we're good
um
I think it just Fades to White here so
there's really not much else to look at
no way too much about this game
milk
oh
look at how cool this shot is
and look the cameras from this angle so
they just put a fog wall over there to
make the shot of the camera look cool
is she gone
yeah she's not there
ghosts America disappeared
you gone
oh this is such a cool shot holy [ __ ] is
my character here nope
okay let's continue
I think he just holds it up and then um
his chest will glow let's look at that
wait
I don't want to get there too early
yep so let's get a little closer
why does the Anvil Rock disappear he
completely destroyed it when he took the
um hammer out of it just completely
bonked it out of existence
I can probably Zoom a little bit better
now
and let's watch the Eldon ring
glow
[Music]
nice
and game time
isn't that interesting to look at it
like that though
I love that [ __ ]
yeah let me look at the Rune a bit
closer
[Music]
so we've got his like uh crisscross
pattern
foreign
what kind of ring is this dog
[Music]
[Music]
wait so the rock broke when radagon took
the hammer out of it but not when
America smashed the Elden ring into it
I guess not
let me get way up in there
[Music]
need
s
I don't know what that is Brent it's
that
okay let's look at his eyes
nothingness
you don't even have eyes bro
did you know the map looks like Godwin's
body
the overall map
no shot
suck on these nuts
dude
I thought it looked like a finger
not like Godwin you can't backstab
radagon by the way
he's been backstabbed too many times to
be able to be backstabbed
foreign
his ass is way thicker than America's
dude trust me if I can figure out how to
remove the cloth
the video I saw I was like oh my God
like her she would be number one on only
fans forever
no cap on a stack okay okay okay okay
okay
okay
wait
pause
camera
underneath oh
I'm not sharing the link there is no
link
where the [ __ ] are you
why is this so weird
he has two swords
what the heck he has two swords
what
what the [ __ ]
why is there two
yeah probably one for the cutscene
can't uh zoom out I'm gonna have to do
this
holy tail
hey let's look at it like this yeah so
like right on the line
yep and then do one of these
increase it a bit grease it a bit
move [ __ ] what the f wait
hovers hovers there's a sword under
there man
oh now he goes and grabs it huh
[Music]
there's his hand above
[Music]
so his hand goes up
this is hard to get like both shots of
it
uppies
oh here we go now we can see both
so he
let's do it like that
it grabs the
it'll grab does it actually push radagon
down to become the sword
because radagon becomes the sword right
so he'll push radagon down
oh we gotta look at that
we gotta look at that
oh that's freaky isn't it
oh it's getting scary
okay he's still got the other sword in
this hand
okay
let's see
there's like also these Rock textures
underneath
another screenshot you think
okay so game speed
he grabbed them under
no it just cuts that'd be so cool if he
pushed him all the way down to become
the sword
let's look at this though
why do Roots come over here these roots
were not here before
were they
damn
look at them toes chat
why all these textures
wait what is that
the game's so much fun to look at when
things are just broke his tail is all
the way over here still
Elden feat
okay
and then
lift
the sword out right
why is he just forming underneath
I'm disappointed in the cuts wait what's
this now
what
we're still up here in the actual
cutscene
dog why all these textures
hello
uh they added another floor
whoa
okay I'm genuinely confused at the
decisions on the textures
but uh
okay
[Music]
I believe he just Rises out correct
oh let's look at the sword real quick
I think this is where our eyes should be
I don't know where we're even at in the
cutscene anymore
like effect of when we release Dustin
death
from malacath as well you guys see that
this
black fog looks exactly the same
could just be a reused asset doesn't
mean anything but
why add that you know
like the same thing bro
ratagon's missing arm
[Music]
I joined and heard Elden feet you joined
at the right time
another what the
okay I'm gonna put it on like two speed
0.2
this fight is just weird isn't it
just black sludge everywhere
what are we supposed to be seeing
this
right here
man they really work with the camera and
that is it that's cool
[Music]
very cool
[Music]
I think it's intended for the floor to
be broken
up he's got his tail back what's going
on down here
here's the other floor
[Music]
what in tarnation
okay let's zoom zoom zoom
this is so much fun okay
and then
laughs
this is the way he rises
from the goop
where does our character come into play
there he is
and then he's gonna shoot all his oh
where'd we end up
where are we
huh
huh
dude there's so many structures
everywhere
the door
yep
that's the door to get in
here
whoa
should we look at it from like here this
feels illegal it is
don't tell the cops
[Music]
whoa
whoa
what
where could that be did we get shot
somewhere else
look at all these layers
that they just keep here
foreign
whoa
yeah I look at Discord
every now and then
hey
I'm gonna go too fast so we don't miss
any
what the [ __ ] yeah look at the look at
the door
[Music]
why would this randomly start glowing
what I'm freaking I'm freaking out right
now man what
all right someone decode it it's Morse
code
[Laughter]
obviously
are we way up here
okay let me let me shoot we're here
okay
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
what where are we
where did they decide to use this asset
[Music]
I mean where we are where are we in
comparison to the door right
okay
and then
we we go somewhere else again
boom
okay
my character should be here now yep
there he is
[Music]
looking all
[Music]
we should do the uh Melina cutscene when
she's the glomide queen too yeah
that'd be sick okay
where are we in comparison to the door I
wonder I think we're really hot
[Music]
yo it's bones
I think that could just be a renewal by
the way bones if you're here I love you
you just became an outer God for nine
months in a row thank you sir
good to see you hope all is well if
you're actually here that could just be
a renewal however
where are we where is this
but thank you bones you're a literal God
you're amazing
okay
chat I am lost
I'm lost in the saucies right now
where are we
okay going back down
just yeeting myself down
[Music]
I'm scared
I promise I'm going somewhere maybe not
it's like the backgrounds
holy [ __ ] Shinola
you can't go to the air trees
all right I think you can okay we're
here
I think they're not even there chat
oh they are
the Eldon B Serena is below radagon's
Arena
I think you're right
okay hold everybody hold hold
going to the tree and it's gonna do
nothing
thick
okay
Goodness Me
I think that's all we're gonna be able
to see chat but that was really cool now
let's kill this guy and look at the
glomide queen one yeah
let's kill this [ __ ]
foreign
I believe the Dragons Were Made of Stone
and Dark Souls yes
foreign
where did the scar come from here
I have returned after seven months of
inactivity
welcome Sam
I'm assuming it's from the shattered
Alden ring right
I'll die
there's radagon
there he is guys isn't that weird
there's this rib cage and his arms
at his appendix taken up
I'm covered in his goopy blood
I haven't finished so don't spoil okay I
don't watch the beginning of the stream
then Conan
let's take a look at this real quick
[Music]
okay
[Music]
why does eldenbeast die like all of
their NPCs
I have no idea bro hold on
[Music]
I'm doing it for you guys
[Music]
the Beast became the ring so America
breaking the ring then it becomes album
Beast again
[Music]
watched berserk
I did not read berserk
I did get a lot of comments saying that
I should read it but I'm not gonna
I watched a video of somebody describing
the manga to me
dude the detail of where her hair is
over the encaved head is so [ __ ] cool
[Music]
shut up chat
I might I literally had someone read it
for me okay
okay
um Lord of frenzied flame yeah let's do
it
[Music]
I didn't watch any Netflix movies okay
hold
hold everything
okay where are we what are we doing
is the light on top of us everything
seems to be in order
you guys are gonna hear everything
[Music]
okay
so we'll look from here
died because cheeks yes exactly
my character should just get up
oh I don't know where I am anymore
wait what happened
they just got rid of America why
hey wait I gotta get close to my
character I think
her head's back on the ground
okay
her head's back on the floor wait what's
going on
are we on a different floor
I don't think so my character hasn't
even gotten up yet
oh that's right it crumbles
you're right
yep check it out check it out check it
out
so it'll crumble
I think it's about to crumble yep
dead
and then character stands
damn you guys see the yams on my
character like God damn bro okay
where are we what's going on
why are we all the way over here
foreign
our head is just gone
[Laughter]
that is funny
[Laughter]
all right
there okay let me zoom out
okay
then do this
it's getting up
and then his head should just like
explode right wait I wanna I wanna see
it from this angle
where it
uh lights on fire because I think the
camera is actually behind our character
here obviously
right and then
it'll go through
and there it is
just kind of lights up that's
interesting
cool
pretty normal
oh
yep he turns around to our character
or to our uh not our character but our
uh yup
look at how they put the lighting on are
like like that just to make it look
better for the scene that's so cool to
me
oh here we go okay
it's the Bill Clinton ending
everything's about the light on fire
chat
but what's Lighting on fire
okay here we go
let's just watch it I think
okay
oh we got the particles everywhere
good
a tarnish Ghost Rider
do they really only put the fire like
right there
I think that's all it takes for the
scene huh and then you'll lift his hands
up and more things light on fire
yep
so crazy how perspective will skew
what's actually on fire what happened
here
oh there we go
it flips sides
America's back chat
why put her here
interesting
they must just use like the same
platform
yeah we got fire I don't know where our
boy went though oh there oh nope that's
America
May chaos take the world boys May chaos
take the world of course of course
and then Light It Up
yep final t-pose for America and then we
got here oh look at this
[Music]
yo
cool
what's down here
probably just lighting right
I'm gonna watch it like this
is this interesting though
I find this stuff to be so cool like how
they the creators decided to set up
scenes like this
and then I think I believe it just Fades
to White right here
America's still back there by the way
her spots even lit up and her head's
back
oh with little fires everywhere
also he's like right on the edge for
some reason
my character
all right is this not sick or what
okay
so if I if I put this on uh my second
Channel what do we call it
okay I think it's just gonna cut to that
and then we're gonna get the glomide
queen
this is a cut scene that I can't uh
pause the game on by the way
nope
camera enabled nope I can't mess with
this scene at all I really wish I could
and go look around dang it bro
I really wish I could look at that and
look around the area that'd be sick okay
no this is a cut scene no it's not is it
really
this is a cut scene I can't stop it
no it's a cutscene I thought it was in
game
no I love to look around here
there's nothing I can do though
yeah I can't pause
dude is this in game right here
Maybe
no it's not wow okay
I can't even pause no you can't stop a
cut scene there are some cutscenes that
are in Game and some that are
pre-rendered and this is pre-rendered
what about this part
to deliver you nope can't stop
can't stop won't stop [ __ ] dude that
would have been so cool to look around
hmm
yeah they are print burns on the
buildings yes Christian
damn it Miyazaki
you freaking [ __ ]
that was pretty cool though right chat
that was cool
no
now I've done Godfrey there's really not
that much of interesting stuff
what the [ __ ] are you Melina why does
everything look so bright
is it always this bright in here
I haven't even opened this door yet
oh I can
they're just dead
or it survives
what are you doing here
yeah totally just arrived by the way
I have broken the game what does it look
like from out here now
who is that oh it's huge
foreign
yep everything's on fire I see you've
just arrived everything's on fire though
I'm literally the Elden Lord okay cat
I might call it there I think that was
really interesting
would you want to see that on the second
Channel like just the highlights of what
we did today
I would love to do that it's definitely
not a main Channel upload
via does not have cheeks however she
does have panties
she literally has her own panties in the
game
I'm gonna try that I'll try it and see
how it goes what do we call it though
like I know it's lore hunting
do I call it like breaking Elden ring or
something
I love how this started
with um
us looking at eyes
you can probably look at more eyes later
on
when you turn on combat in the hold
uh
why would I do that
The Secret of America's yams
breaking hunting oh nope that didn't
roll off the tongue
can't kill huge
I don't control combat I don't think
unless it's that guy
I think Hollow Scout might be like 10
minutes behind
this is such an interesting room
all right guys I'm gonna call it there
though I hope you had fun I would like
to do this more often
if you would like to as well
and let me know
we'll see I'm still working on videos
and stuff but I think that's gonna be it
there is nothing in the great jar and
Caleb I've looked I promise there's just
nothing in it
unfortunately
like the stream do it right now
like the stream it helps a lot and then
watch a 10 minutes of the stream after
and then like it again
and then go watch my new video that I
put out yesterday I'm really proud of
that video I think it's good so I'm
definitely gonna do more streams like
this but I'm gonna be done for the night
I'm gonna go get some food and stuff
appreciate y'all being here
and uh we'll be back sometime soon okay
you just look out for the notifications
bro
just keep a lookout look at that he's
gone
it's strange okay I'm out here guys
thank you very much uh
check out the second Channel go sub to
it if you haven't already it's in the
description I think it's the first thing
in the description and go sub to that to
look out for videos on there too
so I'm out here guys have a great rest
of your day night whatever it is and
I'll see you soon peace out dudes boy